The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Back to cavity QED, back to
the fully quantized radiation
field, back to vacuum
Rabi oscillation.
Let me just recapitulate and
sort of make the transition
from this intense
discussion about homework
to the intellectually
stimulating discussion
about atoms and photons.
So in the semiclassical
description
of the electromagnetic
field, photons
can only be emitted
because we have
a Hamiltonian with the
semiclassical electric field.
So if you don't drive the
system with an electric field,
you cannot stimulate
the emission of photons.
But we know this is
not what happens.
Photons are emitted
into empty space,
photons are emitted
into a vacuum.
And for that we needed
a quantized description
of the electromagnetic field.
We did field
quantization, and we
have now our
quantized Hamiltonian.
And on Monday I
started to discuss
what is sort of the
paradigmatic situation,
the paradigmatic example,
for how you should think
about the vacuum and how you
should think about emission
of photons into the vacuum.
And these are the
vacuum Rabi oscillation
described by the
Jaynes-Cummings model.
So the situation
which I have in mind,
or which you should
have in mind,
is an idealized
situation, but it
has been realized
experimentally.
And some of those
idealized experiments
were recognized
with the Nobel Prize
research of Haroche
and Dave Wineland.
So the situation
is we have an atom,
but it only talks to one mode
of the electromagnetic field,
and we make sure
that the atom only
talks to one mode of the
electromagnetic field
not by eliminating
other modes; they exist.
I mean, an atom can emit
upwards and downwards.
But we surround it with a cavity
which has such a small mode
volume, it has such a small
volume, that the single photon
Rabi frequency is
huge, and therefore
the emission into
this one single mode
dominates over the emission
into all other modes.
So this is a condition that the
single photon Rabi frequency
has to be larger than gamma.
And, of course, we
also have to make sure
that the system is idealized
so the loss of photons because
of losses in the mirror,
or finite reflectivity
in the mirror, also
has to be smaller.
So that means for
several Rabi periods
we have a system which has only
two parts, a two-level atom
and one single
mode of the cavity.
So that's the system
we have in mind,
and we discussed
the Hamiltonian.
We saw that the Hilbert
space of the atom
is excited in ground state, the
Hilbert space of the photons
is spent by the
[? flux ?] states,
but what happens is-- so there's
an infinite number of states,
because of the infinite number
of states of the photon field--
but what happens is the
Hamiltonian couples only
an excited state with n photons
to a ground state with n
plus 1 photons.
So the whole Hilbert
space is segmented now
into just pairs of states
labeled by the index n.
So after so much work, we are
back to a two-level system.
And here is our
two-level Hamiltonian.
And, well, a
two-level system does
oscillations between
the two levels.
Rabi oscillations, no surprise.
And this is what I
want to discuss now.
But the new feature is that
these are really, well,
these are now really two levels.
Each of them is
the combined state
of the atom and the
quantized radiation field.
So now we have included in
our two-level description
the quantum state of the
electromagnetic field.
So first you should realize that
this Hamiltonian is absolutely
identical to spn 1/2
in magnetic fields.
And you can recognize
by [? comparing ?]
this Hamiltonian, this
matrix, to the matrices
we discussed for spn 1/2
in the magnetic field,
that this corresponds
to the situation
where this spn 1/2
had a transverse field
in the x direction which
caused a precession from spn
up to spn down.
And this x component
of the field
corresponds now to the single
photon Rabi frequency times
n plus 1.
That's the off diagonal
matrix element in this matrix.
The thing which we
have to discuss,
and I will focus later,
is that it depends on n.
So for each pairs of state
labeled by n, the photon
number, we have a different
off diagonal matrix element.
But let's discuss first the most
important and simplest case.
Let's assume we
are on resonance,
and we want to assume
that we have a vacuum.
Then our Hamiltonian
is simply this.
And when we prepare the system
in an initial state, which
is an excited state with
no photon in the vacuum,
then we'll have
oscillations to the ground
state with one photon.
These oscillations are
exactly the oscillations
we saw on the spn 1/2 system.
We can just map the solution.
I'm not really
writing anything here.
So what we obtain is the famous
vacuum Rabi oscillations.
where the probability to
be in the excited state
oscillates with the single
photon Rabi frequency omega 1.
I think there's a little bit
of an ambiguity in language.
Is it the single
photon Rabi frequency?
or is it the vacuum
Rabi frequency?
Because there's always
the question about plus
minus one photon because
we start in the excited
state without photon
so you want to say
it's a vacuum Rabi frequency.
But then you have the ground
state with one photon,
and this photon is
reabsorbed and then
you may want to call it the
one photon Rabi frequency.
So I leave it to you, but it's
called vacuum Rabi oscillation
and this Rabi frequency is
usually referred to as the one
photon Rabi frequency
because we obtained the Rabi
frequency by calculating
the electric field
of a single photon.
So the Rabi oscillations
which we are observing now
correspond to the periodic
spontaneous emission
and re-absorption
of the same photon.
There's only one photon
which is spontaneously
emitted and reabsorbed in
a completely reversible
coherent way, and the
time evolution is unitary.
So it's a periodic
spontaneous emission
and re-absorption
of the same photon.
This has been
experimentally observed.
Actually, let me back up.
Experiments are done in
the microwave regime.
The leading groups are,
well, in the older days,
Dan Kleppner, Herbert
[? Weidner, ?]
and Serge Haroche.
And this involves Rydberg atoms.
Rydberg atoms in
superconducting high q cavities.
And those Rydberg
atoms, because things
scale with n and n squared,
the principal quantum number,
have a fantastically
strong coupling
to the electromagnetic field.
And there is a
homework assignment
on Rydberg atoms
in such cavities.
The other example is
in the optical domain.
And this really involves
the D line of alkali atoms.
You drive them on the D line.
rubidium and caesium
are often used,
and the work is enabled
by the development
of so-called supermirrors
which have an extremely
high reflectivity, and you can
realize an excellent q factor.
And the leaders in this field
are Jeff Kimble and Gerhard
Rempe at the Max
Planck Institute.
So let me just
discuss an example
taken from the optical domain.
So the generic
situation is that you
have two mirrors which
define a single mode cavity.
Usually, you have
a stream of atoms.
Traditionally in
atomic beams, then
in some experiments in slowed
atomic beams, more recently
in atoms which are
falling out off the mode,
and only very recently
single atoms with the help
of other laser beams that are
trapped inside the cavity.
So they are streamed
in such a way
that only one or a few atoms
are in the mode volume interact
with a single mode of the
cavity at a given time.
And then you want to figure
out what is now happening,
and you have the probe laser,
you send it through the cavity,
and then you record the
transmission with a photodiode.
Yanosh?
AUDIENCE: What is the mirror
made of for the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The mirror is
made of a glass substrate,
but then you would
[INAUDIBLE] the coating.
And the mastering is
really to put coatings
on which are very
pure, but then also I
think using ion
sputtering, you make
sure that the coating
is extremely smooth
and does not have any
surface irregularities which
would scatter a tiny
fraction of the light.
I know there are some people
in Ike's group and [INAUDIBLE]
group who work with
high q mirrors.
What is a typical example
for the reflectivity?
Or the q factor you can reach?
AUDIENCE: 5 [INAUDIBLE] and
a finesse of, maybe, 500,000.
And they're called
superpolished mirrors.
PROFESSOR: So finesse of
about a million, and that
means the mirrors have
99.9999% reflectivity.
And the superpolishing, I
think, that was the last step.
People had controlled
the materials,
but then they found ways
to make a super polish
and avoid these even
one part per million
scattering by surface roughness.
OK.
So if you do that experiment,
what would you expect?
Well, it's a
[INAUDIBLE] experiment
so if you would scan
the probe laser,
and there is nothing
in it, what you
would expect is you would
just expect a transmission
peak at the cavity resonance.
And if you tune
much further, you
get the next peak at
the free spectral range.
Let me just indicate that.
So this is a case for
0 atoms in the cavity.
If you put 1 photon
in the cavity,
you no longer-- sorry,
1 atom in the cavity,
you're no longer
probing a cavity,
you're really probing
a system, which
is no longer the
cavity by itself.
It's an atom-photon system.
It's a couple system.
And we know it's described by
our two-by-two Hamiltonian,
and this Hamiltonian
has two solutions.
And the two solutions are
split by the one photon Rabi
frequency.
So the two eigenvalues
of our Hamiltonian
are at plus minus
omega 1 photon.
So therefore, for n equals
1, we have a situation
that we have two peaks split
by the single photon Rabi
frequency.
Of course, I have assumed
that great care has
been spent to make sure that
the cavity resonance is right
where the atomic resonance is.
So this is now for 1.
If you have 10 atoms, remember
the two-by-two Hamiltonian
looks the same, but it has the
square root n plus 1 factor.
So neglecting the 1 roughly when
we have 10 atoms in the cavity,
it's square root 10
larger Rabi frequency.
And therefore, we
would expect that we
have now a splitting
of the two modes, which
is square root 10 plus 1 larger.
Actually, I didn't-- sorry,
I have to collect myself now.
I showed you that
the Rabi frequency
scales with square root n
plus 1 in the photon field.
But you should realize
that everything
is [? isometric ?]
between photons and atoms.
It's the complete coupling
And if you would now look--
but I don't want to do it now--
if you would now look what
happens if several atoms are
present in the mode
volume, you would also
get a scaling which is n
plus 1 in the atom number,
because the atom
coupled coherently.
It is actually an effect
of super-radiance,
which we'll discussed later.
So just take my word.
You have the same scaling
with the atom number.
But I have to give you my word
now, because in the experiment
this is what people varied.
AUDIENCE: If they had varied
power or number of photons
instead, like, we couldn't
have drawn these same diagrams,
right?
Because then the top part
of the Lorentzian changes.
If you're changing the photon
number then Lorentzians change.
PROFESSOR: Say again?
AUDIENCE: So, like,
right now, yes, we
are varying the
number of atoms so we
can talk about the splitting.
But if we were varying the
power or the number of photons
instead, then each
of the Lorentzians,
their height would change.
How would you draw
this observation
if you were changing
the photon numbers?
PROFESSOR: You know, I don't
want to go into line shape.
I would probably
be a Lorentzian.
I mean, all I want
to discuss here
is that we have a two-by-two
Hamiltonian, which is split.
And if we have one
atom and one photon,
it is split by the single
photon Rabi frequency.
If we have one atom
and 10 photons,
the atom can of course
absorb and emit only one.
As I derived on
the previous page,
we would have now a Rabi
splitting, which is square root
n plus 1, n being the
number of photons.
But if you would start
in an empty cavity
with 10 atoms in
the excited state,
because all the
atoms are identical,
they would spontaneously
emit together,
and then you would have 10
atoms in the ground state,
and then you would
have 10 photons.
And so maybe this helps you.
If you start with 10 atoms
in the excited state,
they do everything together.
If you have 10 atoms in the
ground state with 10 photons,
and now you have 10
photons and it's clear
the 10 photons lead
to a Rabi frequency,
which is proportional
to the square root of 10
or to the square root of 11.
So therefore, what
you will observe
is you will now observe a
splitting of the single mode
of the cavity which goes by
the square root of n plus 1.
I don't want to discuss the line
shape and the [? strings, ?]
I just want to sort of discuss,
in a way, the eigenvalues
of the Hamiltonian,
and the eigenvalues
are the positions
of the transmission
peaks with a cavity.
And that has been observed.
I mentioned the two
leaders of the field
are Gerhard Rempe
and Jeff Kimble.
Well, Gerhard Rempe,
he did his Ph.D.
In the same group
at the same time
as I did so I know
him very well.
Then he went and did post
doc work with Jeff Kimble,
and now is the Director of
the Max Planck Institute.
He has the world leading
group in cavity QED.
But this is sort of here
the two leaders have
a joint paper, which is the
first observation of the vacuum
Rabi splitting in
an optical cavity.
Of course, you can
easily observe it
if you have a strong atomic
bean with many atoms,
because then you
have a good signal.
And secondly, the splitting
is large and easily resolved.
So what they managed to do is
they managed to throttle down
the atomic beam that fewer and
fewer atoms at the given time
were in the cavity.
And eventually they came down
to the limit of one atom.
That was an historic experiment.
Of course, it's not
perfect in the sense
that you do not see the deep
cut between the two peaks simply
because, when on average you
have one atom in the cavity,
sometimes you have to
atom in the cavity,
and then you have a
peak in the middle.
So those experiments
in those days
were done only with
average atom numbers
and not with trapped atoms
where you know for sure there's
exactly one atom in the cavity.
OK.
So I don't show
you an experiment,
but let me just state that
this sort of single photon Rabi
flopping has been observed.
You start with the cavity
in the vacuum field,
and you sort of see
this oscillation
to the ground state
with one photon.
But what I want to discuss
now is the situation
that we are not starting
with an empty cavity.
We are starting with
a coherent field.
You can also start
with a thermal field
so there are different
experiments you can do.
What would we expect now?
So now the initial
photon state is not
the vacuum state, but
the thermal state.
If you have a microwave
cavity and you heat it
up a little bit, you have to
cool it down to below 1 Kelvin.
People use either helium-free
chrio stats or dilution
refrigerators, but if you
warm it up a little bit,
you have a few microwave
photons in the cavity.
Or, that's even more controlled,
you can make the cavity ice
cold, but then you inject a few
photons from your synthesizer
into it-- from your
microwave generator--
and then you have a
weak coherent field.
But a thermal state
or a coherent state.
So what we then have is,
OK, we would expect now
a Rabi oscillation; however, the
frequency for the Rabi flopping
is now proportional to n plus 1.
And we have our photon
field in the superposition
of flux states.
So the fact that we have a
superposition state implies now
that the Rabi oscillations
have a different oscillation
frequency for the different
[? tablets ?] of states labeled
by n.
And that leads to a dephasing.
So that would mean that if you
would look at the probability
to be in the excited
state-- just think about it.
You have a wave function where
the atom starts in the excited
state, and the photon field
is in a superposition.
So now you have a
two-component wave function
which has different
parts, and each part
has a specific Rabi frequency.
So you would have oscillations.
Let's say there is a
certain probability
that the cavity
is in the vacuum,
and then that means that there
is a component which oscillates
at the vacuum Rabi
oscillation frequency.
But if you have a
component in your coherent
or thermal state which
has two photons in it,
then you have Rabi
oscillations which are faster.
And now you have to
superimpose them all.
And if you all
superimpose them, and you
find that very soon there
is a damping and maybe
a little bit of
vigor, but you see
at damping of the population
in the excited state.
Q [? 2 ?] dephasing.
I'm just hesitating.
I think I took this
plot out of my notes,
but I would expect now the
damping should actually
lead to a probability to be
in the excited state of 1/2.
So let me just try
to correct that.
So there is a little
bit of oscillation,
but then there is
sort of a damping.
And eventually, if you
have only a small number
of photon states,
then there will
be a time where you
have sort of at least
a partial commensurability.
You have maybe five frequencies.
You know, square root 5,
square root 4, square root 3,
square root 2.
But then there is
sort of a time where
all these different frequencies
have done an integer
number of oscillations
each, and then you
get what is called a revival.
And if you go to a
large photon number,
you have square root 100,
square root 99, square root 88,
the revival will happen
at a later and later time
and eventually at infinite times
if you use a microscopic field.
But for small coherent
states, or thermal states,
which only involve
a few photons,
you will get a
revival phenomenon.
And this has indeed
been observed.
This was actually the PhD
thesis of Gerhard Rempe,
and it shows the probability
in the excited state.
They had previously observed
the Rabi oscillations
at early times, but
now the experiment
had to be adjusted, I think
by using slower atoms,
to observe the longer time.
And here, well, 1987 for
the first time revivals
have been seen.
Let me dwell on that,
or first are there
any questions about
what happens now?
Atoms in the cavity
to Rabi oscillations?
And if the photon field
is a superposition
of only a few states due to
this pseudo commensurability,
you find times where
you have revivals.
I just worked out
something this morning
which I think is nice,
because it will highlight
how you should think about
spontaneous emission.
So let me discuss.
It doesn't really
matter, but I want
to give you a specific example
that we have a coherent state.
A lot of you know what a
coherent photon state is.
For those who don't,
it doesn't really
matter for what I want
to explain, and recover
that in [? 8.4.22. ?]
But if you have a laser or if
you have a microwave generator,
what comes out is a field which
has a normalized amplitude
of alpha, but your field
is in a superposition
state or [? flux ?] states.
With these prefactors, I just
wanted to give you an example.
What I really just
mean is that we
have a coherent superposition
of number states.
We have prepared that.
So now we have one atom
in the excited state,
it enters the cavity
which has been prepared
with the short pulse
for a laser or microwave
synthesizer in
these state alpha.
And now we want to discuss--
so this is at t equals 0--
and now I want to discuss what
happens as a function of time.
Well, we know that if
you have one tablet,
n, we have Rabi oscillations
between the atoms
in the excited state,
and we have n photons.
Or it has emitted the
photon, and then we
have n plus 1 photon
and the cavity.
But now, we have a
superposition state,
and we have amplitudes an.
So I mean, that's what we get.
And this includes everything.
It includes everything
a two-level atom
does in a single
mode of a cavity.
And this is spontaneous
emission, stimulated emission,
and reabsorption.
But I want to use
that now to discuss
with you the misconceptions
about spontaneous emission.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: We're talking about
just spontaneous emissions
into the cavity?
PROFESSOR: OK.
I've singled out a single mode.
But what happens is-- and you're
just two minutes, 30 seconds,
ahead of me-- that we
had discussed vacuum Rabi
oscillations or Rabi
oscillations when
we have n photons in the cavity.
This was our two-level system,
our Hamiltonian, and all
we get is Rabi oscillations
with the Rabi frequency omega n.
And now we have to
sort of do averaging.
I'm now discussing that we
have a coherent superposition
of number states.
Let's say, a pulse of coherent
radiation, a coherent state,
and this is what we get.
You can now, if you want, put in
a [? zillion ?] of other modes,
have another sum over all
the other modes you want.
So I'm just doing the
first step in discussing
with you what will happen,
but adding more and more
modes will actually not change
the structure of the answer
and will be, of course,
quantitatively a mess
but conceptually not
more complicated.
So I want you to
really look at that
and realize where
is the spontaneity
of spontaneous emission.
Where do you see any form
of randomness associated
with spontaneous emission
in this expression?
I don't see it.
This is a wave function, and
this time evolution is unitary.
Everything is deterministic,
and depending now
how we choose our coefficient,
there is even a revival.
It's not dissipative that
a photon is spontaneously
emitted, and it's done.
We saw in the single
photon Rabi oscillation
it can be reabsorbed, we saw
in a slightly more complicated
situation that there are
at least partial revivals,
and it now depends
how long we wait
whether revivals will
take place or whether they
will be complete revivals
or partial revivals.
But we don't need a revival
in a coherent evolution,
the coherent evolution can
just go to a complicated wave
function and it's still a
single coherent wave function
fully deterministically obtained
form the Hamilton operator.
Sometimes it pops into our
eyes through a reversible
oscillation or through revival,
but we don't need that.
So let me write it down but
then explain you something.
So it's unitary.
There is no spontaneity at all.
However, eventually we want to
retrieve the classical limit.
So if we would go
to this situation
that the average photon
number is much smaller than 1,
then the fluctuation
in the photon field
around the mean
number are very small.
For the coherent state the
fluctuations are square root n.
And then, we retrieve the
limit of semiclassical Rabi
flopping with the
Rabi frequency omega
r, which is-- I'm not consistent
here with lower and uppercase
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's uppercase or
lowercase omega n,
and this is square root n
times the single photon Rabi
frequency.
And, of course, for a
large number of photons,
we can always make
the approximation
that we do not
have to distinguish
between n and n plus 1.
So this is the
ultimate limit if we
would work in the limit
of large photon numbers.
So the way how you should
look at it is the following.
This system undergoes
a time evolution
to a state which is
rather complicated.
But if you make
the number n large,
this becomes
approximately a state
where you have
simply-- you know what
the rate of the
semiclassical limit?
In the semiclassical limit,
we have a constant laser beam
with constant electric
field amplitude, e,
and then we have driven
Rabi oscillations
between ground
and excited state.
So therefore, I don't want
to show you mathematically,
but in the limit of large
n, you can approximate
this complicated
entangled wave function
by the product of
Rabi oscillations
between ground and excited state
times a coherent photon field.
And the correction
between what I just said
and this complicated wave
function is like 1 over n,
because it's sort of a
1 over n approximation
where we have
neglected terms which
the relative importance
of them is 1 over n.
So therefore, there
are people who will say
and who will tell
you when we have
an interaction of an atom
with a coherent state,
and let's just think in the
number of n being large,
that n times out of n plus
1, we have a coherent state.
The atom does Rabi
oscillation and what
it does is it just emits
photon into the coherent field
and takes it back, like
in semiclassical physics.
But in one case out of
n cases, or the rate
1 over n of the rate of the
wave function is sort of fuzzy.
It's not a coherent
state; it's something
much more complicated.
And if you do not keep track
of this complicated nature
of the wave function and just
do some simple measurement by,
let's say, just
measuring the phase
of the electromagnetic
wave by projecting
onto a coherent
state, then you would
find that with the
probability of n
the system was just staying
in a coherent state.
And with a probability
which is one part out of n,
something else has happened,
and your detector cannot capture
the entanglement of that state.
And this last part
is what some people
associate with
spontaneous emission.
I don't know.
That's my view where the
spontaneity in this process is.
It's not a spontaneity
in the time evolution.
It's more a spontaneity
if you do not
care to detect this
complexity, but map it back
to a coherent state.
And then with a precision
which is 1 over n,
you retrieve the
semiclassical limit,
but the difference between
the semiclassical limit
and the entangled wave function,
this is what some people say
is spontaneous because it's not
captured by a single picture.
I'm actually expecting some
people to disagree with me,
but this is sort
of my view, what
I'm sort of learning from
the simple examples I've
given to you.
Since Ike is an expert
on it, maybe, Ike,
can I ask you the question is
there actually a simple way
to show that if I go
to a large n limit
that you can sort of really show
that n parts out of n plus 1
is really described fully
by the semiclassical limit
and there is only
a 1 over n fraction
where we have to look at the
more complicated wave function?
AUDIENCE: I don't think
there's a simple way to do it,
but one can look
at the equivalence
of a [? and a factor ?]
state, and they're only
different by one photon number.
PROFESSOR: It's sort of clear.
I mean, everything is if you
approximate n by n plus 1.
If you don't care about
the small difference,
everything falls into
place and is simple.
But I was just
wondering if one could
show sort of in a more direct
or more intuitive or maybe
more quantitatively
what is really
the extra part beyond
stimulated emission
absorption into
the coherent state.
So what sort of
really the nature
of what people call the
spontaneously emitted photon?
AUDIENCE: I think that I don't
the question, because I still
argue that it's purely
[? unitary ?] evolution even--
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: For that system,
and therefore, it's
purely [INAUDIBLE] and
nothing spontaneous
is happening at all.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right.
Good.
OK.
Fine.
What is next?
I think this finishes our
discussion on vacuum Rabi
oscillations and revivals.
I have now two
topics in light atom
interaction which you may
not find in many textbooks,
but it's my experience that
they're really relevant.
One is very conceptual.
It's about the rotating
wave approximation.
And the other one is just
the opposite, very technical.
It's not really a
new concept, but this
is about saturation
intensities and cross-section
of an atom for absorption.
The last things, cross-section
for absorption and saturation
intensity, that's
what you need when
you talk to atoms
in the laboratory.
These are the quantities in
which we think intuitively
about light atom interaction.
So it's not involving
any concept.
I want to spend 20 minutes in
introducing for you saturation,
saturation parameter,
cross-section,
what's different between
monochromatic light
and broadband light.
But before I do that,
I have a few minutes
on the rotating
wave approximation.
So let's call it rotating
wave approximation revisited.
Again, rotating
wave approximation.
And what I want to discuss
can be discussed in
the fully quantized
picture, but also
in the semiclassical picture.
In the fully quantized
picture, just a reminder,
what we discussed
earlier was that when
we have the atomic
raising and lowering
operator and the photonic
raising and blowing operator,
we got four terms.
And two of the terms
are co-rotating,
two are counter-rotating.
But I can get exactly
the same number
of four terms in this
semiclassical picture,
and I want you to see both.
But in the quantized picture,
it's actually easier,
because when you see a
and [? a dega, ?] you
know immediately one is
absorption one is emission.
So therefore let
me explain to you
what I want to tell you
about the rotating wave
approximation using the
semiclassical picture,
because then you
immediately know
how to apply it to
the quantized picture.
So what I want to bring in the
here in addition to what we
have discussed about
light atom interaction,
we had sort of a
dipole Hamiltonian,
is the fact that we have
circular polarized light,
left-handed and
right-handed light,
and I want to sort of
use that and combine it
with angular momentum selection
roles, which as you remember
we discussed after our
discussion of dipole,
quadrupole, and magnetic
dipole positions.
So I put now all
those parts together
and revisit the rotating
wave approximation.
So what I hope for is it
tells you a little bit
how selection roles,
angular momentum,
circular polarization,
and semiclassical field
which rotate in one direction
how they are all connected.
So I have to set
up the situation
by saying that we use as a
quantization axis the direction
k, which is either the
direction of the propagation
of the light beam
or, in general,
it's orthogonal to
the polarization
of the electric
and magnetic field.
And I can talk about an
electric field driving
an electric dipole transition.
I can talk about
a magnetic field
driving a magnetic transition.
It doesn't really matter.
I will use [? Bsc ?]
amplitude, but you can also
immediately think
electric dipole,
and this field is
linearly polarized.
But I want to immediately
decompose this field
into right-handed and
left-handed field.
Or a linearly
polarized field can
be regarded as a superposition
of a field which circulates
this way plus one which
circulates the other way.
And ultimately, the
message we will see
is that if you have
linearly polarized light,
we always get counter-rotating
term, we always
have a [INAUDIBLE]
shift and such.
But if you use rotating fields
or circularly polarized light,
selection roles may
actually lead to the result
that there is no
counter-rotating term at all.
So this is eventually
what I'm aiming for,
and this will be the final
point of the discussion.
So the field which rotates
in the right-handed direction
where the rotating field is
a superposition of x and y,
or i and j.
And one the rotates
has a cosine omega t
and one has sine omega t.
I don't need to write
down the left-handed part,
because there's
just a minus sign.
Or this will actually
become very handy.
I do all the discussion
for the right-handed part,
but I can always
obtain the expression
for the left-handed part by
replacing omega by minus omega.
Which will mean that
some emission process
by the right-handed part
will be an absorption
process by the left-hand part.
Be we'll see.
You can change angular
momentum by plus 1
by absorbing a right-handed
photon or-- you'll see.
We'll get there.
So anyway, those signs
will become important.
Let me now take the
above expression
for the right-handed part
and replace cosine omega t
and sine omega t by
e to the i omega t.
So this was the i component,
this was the j component.
We divide by 2.
Just to avoid confusion,
I want to emphasize
I've started with a real field.
So I'm not using, as you often
do in e and m complex field
and the real fields
are the real part,
I have not started
out by adding,
you know, imaginary
parts to the field.
I've started out with a
linearly polarized field
in the x direction
cosine omega t,
and I've decomposed it
into two real fields.
One is right-handed,
one is left-handed.
Complex numbers
only come because I
want to use a complex
exponential to replace
cosine omega t and sine omega t.
We are almost done with the
decomposition of the field.
I just wanted to-- we
have now four terms,
and I want to [? recoup ?] them.
i minus imaginary unit j.
i plus imaginary unit j.
This is e to the i omega t.
And this is e to
the minus i omega t.
So what have we done?
Well, we've just started with
linearly repolarized light,
and I've rewritten
the expression twice,
and now we are looking only at
one of the circular components,
and in the end what
we have is four terms.
Well, that's also what we
had in the fully quantized
Hamiltonian, and we now want to
identify what those four terms.
Two will be co-rotating, two
will be counter-rotating,
but it's very helpful
to analyze those terms.
But there are two things
we have to look at now.
One is we have an
e to the i omega t.
And, well, it's probably
a sign convention,
but trust me, if you put that
in the Schrodinger equation,
it mean that you increase
the energy of the atom
if you drive it with
e to the i omega t.
You take it from a ground state
to an excited state, which
differs in frequency by
omega, and therefore this
means you have increased
the energy of the system,
and this corresponds
to absorption.
Whereas this one here
means we take an atom
from an excited state
to a ground state,
and this is the situation
of stimulated emission.
Remember, in selection
roles we take our field
and we multiply it
with a dipole moment,
electric, magnetic
dipole moment whatever.
But now we want to use also the
spherical tensor decomposition
of those dipole moments.
It's a complicated
word, but what
it means is those terms are
dotted with the dipole moment,
and if you do it now
component-by-component,
we retrieve selection roles
because this peaks out the--
let me just write it
down-- the x plus y
tensor component of
the matrix element.
And this corresponds to
delta m equals plus 1.
We change the angular
momentum by one unit,
and of course this term is
then delta m equals minus 1.
So we have done the work.
What I want to do now is
just map those terms into
and energy level diagram.
I like sort of pictorial
representations,
and each term becomes now
a graphical [INAUDIBLE].
So let us assume we have a
system, hydrogen is to p state.
But let's say generally we
go from a j equals 0 to j
equals 1 state, which
has three components.
Now, I have set it up in
such a way that-- oops,
we need a little
bit extra space.
I've set it up in such a way
that the states here, this
is m equals 0, this
is m equals plus 1,
and this is m equals minus 1.
So therefore-- let
me just use color
coding now-- this one here
is delta m equals plus 1
so this one always
moves to the right.
It changes angular momentum
by 1 so it can always
move to the right, whereas
the other one, delta m
equals minus 1,
moves to the bank.
Absorption is e to the i
omega t, always moves up.
And stimulated
emission moves down.
So with that what
happens is this term here
transfers one unit of
angular momentum and energy.
So that would mean
this term goes up here.
It could go up here, if
[? there were a ?] state.
The other term-- let me use
a green color-- is driving
the process in the
opposite direction.
But now we have to also consider
that you can go down here,
and you can go down
to a virtual state.
A virtual state
is just something
which has the same wave
function as a state,
it just has an e to
the i omega t, which
is not-- it's a driven system.
You drive it.
You [INAUDIBLE] a state.
You [INAUDIBLE] a state
at the drive frequency,
and it just means, in
this case, this state
has an oscillation e to the i
omega t, which is very, very
different from what a state
which is populated would have,
and this is what we
call a virtual state.
So in other words,
what is possible is
we have our three states,
plus minus 1 and 0,
but this is the
spatial wave function
including angular momentum.
But we can now drive it by
plus omega and minus omega,
and therefore we can
have it as virtual states
pretty much at any
energy we want.
But this process
here is not possible,
because this would require
to go to a state which has m
equals 2, which does not exist.
So now what I've
shown here is if we
would stock in the
m equals 0 state,
I've shown you the four
terms, two are co-rotating
and two are counter-rotating.
If you neglect this
virtual state which
has a detuning of about
2 omega, or 2 resonance
frequency of the atom,
this is the rotating wave
approximation.
One term is responsible
for absorption;
the other term is responsible
for a stimulated emission.
But if I don't make the
rotating wave approximation,
I have those two extra terms.
So this is only the
right-handed light,
and I want to sort of play a
little bit with this concept.
If I would take the
left-handed light,
I would add sort of
four more arrows.
Two more here and two more here.
But let's just
keep the situation
as simple as possible.
But I really sort
of like that you
write down right-handed,
left-handed side,
decompose it into
its components,
and each component is now
in this diagram connected
to an arrow where one
direction is angular momentum,
the other one is energy.
So let me now talk about
other energy diagrams.
And this will lead
to the answer.
Well, can we create
a situation where
we have only two terms,
which would be the simplest
two-level system, can
be directly realized
without any rotating
wave approximation
a two-level system?
So if we had two levels,
which have only m
equals 0 and m equals 1.
So this would be
the situation I just
discussed with those two levels.
So the only way how I can fit
in this arrow is this one,
and the diagonally
downward arrow is that.
So in this case, rotating
wave approximation
is not an approximation,
it is exact.
But some purists will
actually say, hey,
you can never realize
that when you have an n
equals plus 1 state.
Then you always have an
m equals minus 1 state.
And then you have a
virtual state down there,
and then you get two
more terms, which
are the counter-rotating terms
which I just showed above.
So whole I would say if you
have a neutron star which
makes an infinitely
high magnetic field,
you can have a huge
[INAUDIBLE] splitting between m
equals plus 1 and
m equals minus 1
and completely move one
of the angular momentum
states out of the picture.
But, of course, in the
rotating wave approximation
we are neglecting off resonant
terms at 2 omega, omega
being an electronic
excitation energy,
so I'm really talking
about Zeeman shifts
here to eliminate
the other state which
may be comparable to
electronic energies.
So in principle, I can say
this is my Hilbert space,
and in this Hilbert space no
rotating wave approximations
is needed.
But it's maybe an
artificial Hilbert space.
When I had a discussion
with other people,
we came up with the possibility
of some forbidden transition.
If you go from a doublet
s to a doublet s state
so all you have is
a spin system which
has 1/2 angular momentum
plus 1/2 minus 1/2.
And then you realize
that the only way how
you can fit in the
orange arrow is
in this way, and the
green arrow in this way.
So here you would
have a situation
where the rotating wave
approximation is exact.
But, of course, it's not an
electric dipole transition;
it's some sort of weaker
conversation, which
may be forbidden.
I need two more minutes.
I have discussed the case
where we have quantized
along a direction, I
called it the k direction,
and the polarization of
the electromagnetic field
was [? i and j ?] was
perpendicular to it.
So let me now discuss a
case where we quantize along
the polarization of the
electromagnetic field,
and you remember from our
discussion on selection roles
that this is pi light.
So in this case, our
magnetic or electric field
is polarized along
the i direction,
and the real cosine omega t gets
decomposed into e to the plus
e to the minus i omega t.
And we know already one term
is absorption one is emission.
And now, if I take my j
equals 0 to j equals 1 system,
pi light has a selection
role of delta m equals 0.
So now I have an arrow,
which I want to be orange,
which goes up.
And a green arrow--
this is a great program.
The only thing is you have
to be very careful when
you change color
and press carefully.
That's why sometimes the colors
are not doing what I want.
But here is green.
But now, of course, with
linearly polarized light
we can always go down
to a virtual state.
We have now four terms.
Two are rotating, two
are counter-rotating.
So therefore the
quick conclusion
of the last ten minutes is
that there is the possibility
that counter-rotating
terms can be
0 for sigma plus sigma minus
light due to angular momentum
selection roles.
But what we have also learned is
if you have the m plus 1 state
in there's an m minus state, if
you have circularly polarized
light and we drive a transition
between two m states,
the counter-rotating
term does not
come from the same set of
two states, m equals 1.
It involves m equals minus 1.
So it's the other state which
is maybe degenerate or only
slightly [? split ?] by
a magnetic field which
is responsible for the
counter-rotating terms.
Anyway we have talked so
much about rotating wave
approximation and
those terms, I just
wanted to show you
how it is modified
if you use degeneracy p
states and angular momentum.
Any question?
OK.